now there's another fundamental question
which is what makes the difference
between different materials and the
other question is how do we model it
well different materials reflect
incoming light to different directions
and they absorb different amounts of it
in different wavelengths that's the
answer we are going to talk a lot about
this but this is an example these are
different materials so the specular in
the specular case there is one incoming
direction and there is one possible
outgoing direction that's it this is
what always happened this is for
instance a mirror because I see exactly
the reflection of myself there's there's
no no other thing that I see in the
mirror but for a diffused surface for
one incoming direction there is many
possible outcomes in many possible
directions and this gives the diffuse
surface we're going to see examples of
that and it rates it rights spread
please forget this term let's call this
floor single step because this is what
it is this is like the mixture of these
two
so these are some basic material models
that we are going to see in our
renderers later on now to formalize this
in a way let's create a function that's
a probability density function with
three parameters so this is a three
dimensional function one variable is the
incoming light direction the other
variable is a point on the surface and
what I'm interested in is how much light
is flowing out from this point in
different directions now a bit more
formalized this F R is going to be this
function I'm interested in the incoming
direction and the point in space
this is this two is what I have and I
will be interested in
putting directions what is the
probability of different outcome
interactions and this is how we how we
will write it formally Omega is an
incoming direction direction X is a
point in space that we choose and Omega
prime is the outgoing direction and this
we call the brdf for bi-directional
reflectance distribution function so
this is a very complicated name for
something that's very simple
they RDF now what about materials that
don't reflect all incoming light there
are some materials that transmit some of
it so for instance glass or gemstones
and such well it's it could look like
that and here above you can see some
DRDs and below you can see some some
things because it's not reflected it's
transmitted there are some materials
that let them feel so here's an example
well everyone had seen windows and
things like that well the question is
why like just a physical question why
are these objects transparent sorry do
it for everyone yes they transmit the
light but what is happening here exactly
so just some physical intricacy that the
most fundamental question you know what
is inside of an atom and the best answer
is nothing because an atom is 99% empty
space there is the nucleus which is the
whole atom is the size for instance of a
football field if you imagine that that
the nucleus is a small piece of rice in
the middle of the football field that's
the nucleus and the electrons are also
very small things like small Rice's
which are orbiting this look leus from
very far away like the side sides of the
football
and in between there's nothing
absolutely nothing so the more
interesting question would be why is not
everything transparent I mean there is
absolutely nothing in there that would
divert that or absorb the light all
right everything just everything should
go through why is not everything
transparent not only glass but
everything and the reason is absorption
so these electrons are orbiting to look
loose and what essentially is happening
is that electrons can absorb photons
photons are if you imagine light as not
raised or not waves but particles then
fall is the basic particle of life so
electrons they absorb photons and if
they do they go from an inner orbit like
a lower energy level they jump to a
higher energy level because it it's
basically you after lunch you eat
something you get more energetic you get
you get more jumpy so it it jumps to an
outer orbit from the nucleus it's a bit
further away so it absorbs the light so
the light doesn't go through so this is
why most things are not transparent but
the question is why is then glass
transparent and the answer is that these
words these different places around the
nucleus they are so far apart that in
the visible light spectrum if the
electrons absorb a photon they don't get
enough energy to jump to the next orbit
and this is why oh this is why most of
the light is going through these glass
materials and thing is that this is not
always the case this is the case for
visible light spectrum days
spectrum which is absorbed so if you
have a spectrum that if that is a higher
energy spectrum then it may give enough
energy for this electron to jump to a
different orbit and we can easily find
out what spectrum it is because for
instance we use glass for a number of
different beneficial things well for
instance you cannot get sunburn if you
are inside of the house and you have
your windows closed and we are wearing
sunglasses in order to protect our eyes
from something so is there someone who
tells me what this spectrum is that
exactly just a bit louder
you will ultraviolence ultraviolence a
hot is a spectrum with a higher of a lot
of energy is and and if you absorb it
then this job is possible so this is why
it is observed so just some physical
intricacies so lights may get reflected
if we have a material that most of the
time reflects light and we call it the
brdf the R is the interesting part is
the reflection and if it transmittance
is possible with a material model we
have the bTW D F which is the
bi-directional transmittance
distribution function and as an umbrella
term for both of these this is basically
the whatever term is BS DF so by
direction of scattering distribution
function I'm not saying this because
this is lots of fun I'm saying this
because you're going to find this these
terms in the literature all the time
so BSD F is basically things that
reflect and things that transmit
okay what are the properties of the RDX
and after this we suddenly put together
something beautiful very ready so there
is Helmholtz reciprocity it means that
the direction of the ray of light can be
reversed when it means mathematically is
that I can swap the incoming and
outgoing directions and I'm going to get
the same probabilities so the
probability of going here to there is
the same probability as coming from
there to here if I look at things from
both sides I will get the same
probabilities so that's that's often
useful in physics positivity this is
self explanatory well it cannot be less
than zero probability cannot be less
than zero
for every outgoing direction there is
some positive probability or there is
zero that's it if nothing else is really
possible so formally this is how it
looks like and it makes some
mathematicians awfully happy and there's
energy conservation perhaps the most
important property an object may reflect
or absorb incoming light but it is
impossible that more is coming out and
the incoming amount well obviously we
have light sources and things like that
but we are talking about three key
material models so this means that if I
integrate this function for all possible
incoming directions then I get if I take
into consideration light attenuation
that we
talked about this is why it is so hot at
noon and why it is so cold at night then
I'm going to get one for less and this
is because if it equals one that this
means that this kind of material
reflects all light that comes in and if
it's less than one then this means that
some amount of light is absorbed okay we
are almost there at the rendering
equation generally what we are going to
do is that we pick a point X and this
direction is going to point towards the
camera or my eye this is basically nice
the same thing it's just an abstraction
and what I am going to be doing is I'm
going to sum up all the possible
incoming directions where light can come
to this point and I've interested in how
much is impacted towards my direction
and let's not forget that objects can
emit light themselves and we will also
compute this reflected amount of five so
just intuition light exiting the surface
towards my eye is the amount that it
emits itself if it's a light source and
the amount that it reflects from the
incoming light that comes from its
surroundings and this is how we can
formally write this with this beautiful
integral equation let's see let's tear
it somewhere and see what means what
this is the emitted light so this is
light from point X going towards my eye
how much is it while the amount that is
in point X and beat it towards my eye if
it's a light source like that one then I
definitely have this amount and there is
an amount the very fact that that is
reflected let's see what's going on this
is what I just told you and again and
this is the integration this is
interesting part so I am integrating
this Omega Prime so all possible
incoming directions what you have seen
the hemisphere on the previous image
hemisphere means basically half the one
half of the sphere we are integrating
over a hemisphere not over a few not
over a full sphere because if we take
into consideration the cosine if the
light comes from above that cosine 0
degrees is 1 and as I rotate this light
source around this point then this
cosine will get to 90 degrees so from
here to there and the cosine of 90
degrees is 0 therefore there's going to
be no throughput if it comes from that
direction and if I have something that's
higher that would be negative we don't
deal with these cases so this is why I
am integrating over a hemisphere so
sunlight is coming to this point in
different directions and what I'm
interesting is interested in is how much
is this of this light is reflecting
towards my eye this is multiplied by the
incoming radiance there is the brdf and
light attenuation that's it this is
still a bit difficult this is still a
bit elusive so first we are going to
train ourselves like bodybuilders on
smaller weights so we are going to
create an easier version of this because
apparently this is terribly difficult to
solve if you take a look and if you will
sit down and try to solve it for a
difficult scene where you have objects
and geometries and and different BRD
have different material models you will
find that this is impossible to solve
analytically and one of the first
problems is yes this is the question
just for one point right so we are
looking at
exactly yes and and here comes the catch
so I'm interested in how much light is
going towards my hair from this point
how much is it well it depends if I turn
on other light sources then this point
is going to be brighter because the
radiance coming out of this point
depends on its surroundings is the
window open are the curtains
cold or not so X is point X depends on
this other point y for instance all
other points then we can say okay let's
not compute this X first let's compute
this Y point instead first because then
I will know X okay but this Y also
depends on X because how bright light is
on the other side of the room also
depends on how bright it is in this side
of you so there is some recursion in
there and it's if you if you don't think
out of the box this is impossible to
solve because you don't know where to
start this integral is hopeless to
compute in closed form because there may
be shapes and different objects in there
and this will make integration in that's
difficult the integral is infinite
dimensional later you will see that if I
compute one binds this X that I have
been talking about that's okay but I
need to compute multiple bounces I need
to start tracing rays from the camera
and see how much light is entering the
lens of the camera
that one bounce is not enough is two
bounces enough so after the X icon I
can't
somewhere else is this enough say
something it's not enough okay but I
think maybe three is enough is three
enough it's not enough okay well you
guys are very picky okay is ten bounces
enough okay why not because there's
still some amount of energy left that if
I would continue this light path I would
encounter other objects and I don't have
any knowledge of that we need to compute
an infinite amount of bounces even 1,000
is Mario so and this rendering equation
is going to be 1.1 pounds and if I want
to compute the second bounce that's
going to be embedded there's going to be
embedded another integral equation
another rendering equation and this goes
on infinitely this is the biggest
equation in the whole universe it's
impossible to solve and it is often
singular I will later show you why so
even if you would want to integrate it
you could so this is horribly difficult
this seems impossible and apparently at
this point we cannot solve it so this is
the end of the course and we have any
possible problem there is no reason even
to try and goodbye see you never because
there's never gonna be any more lectures
but in order to understand what's going
on first we're going to put together a
simpler version of this equation that we
can understand and we can
more going on there's another
formulation of the rendering equation
I'm not going to deal with this too much
you can imagine this other version as
moving points around so there is a light
source in P 3 and there is the sensor at
P Zero and this is one example light
path and what I'm doing is I'm not
stopping at one point and integrating
all possible incoming directions
because this is what I did with your
original formulation what I do is I
compute one by path i compute how much
light is going through I add that to the
sensor and then I move this p2 around I
move it a bit I compute a new life but
how much is going through I move this p2
around again so imagine this moving
everywhere and imagine also p1 moving
everywhere so all these points are
moving everywhere and I compute the
contribution of this light source to the
sensor so this is another kind of
integration I'm not going to go through
this what is interesting is that there
is a geometry turning there and this
describes the geometric relation of
different points and light attenuation
between them I'm not going to deal with
this too much I just put it here because
if you are interested then chew your way
through it
in literature they often write it this
way